I'm David Wilkes and I am an assistant scout master with Troop 68 in Dallas, Texas.
This edition of the Scout Master podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now the old scout master,
Tony the clava, is a cub master with pack eight fifty eight and also works with
Boy Scout Troop 581 in Bristol, Virginia.
He had a situation that he wanted a little help with.
He said that on a recent camping trip he lost his mood ring and he doesn't know
how to feel about it. lost his mood.
Okay,
So hands up all those who know what a mood ring is.
Yeah, you're old like me.
Thanks, Tony,
I think.
Hey, this is podcast number two thirty eight.
Welcome back to the Scout Master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
We're going to look at the mailbag and if I'm I know I'm a little behind on
my email correspondence.
There's been an awful lot in the past week or so,
So be patient with me.
I'll get. I'll get to you,
But this past week we heard from Aaron Weissman, who is a scout master
with Troop 1026 in Great Falls, Montana.
He said we just had our fall corner of honor after summer camp.
We were giving away awards for a full 49 minutes.
Well, at least he kept a clock on it.
That's good
And we're not a very large troop.
One great idea is to make a court of honor into a potluck dinner.
We've done this for the past few years and it really encourages
attendance, especially since we have grandparents and other
family members coming.
I also send out a note to the families of each boy getting
an award the day before, to make sure they know about it.
Thanks, Aaron, for getting in touch.
That email came in response to a post we had on the blog last
week. that is basically like a court of honor FAQ, and more
about that in a moment.
Dave Klein is an assistant scout master with Troop 918.
And he said we hold a leadership training camp out for each
incoming group of leaders.
This weekend will be our second experience doing this training
using articles from Enoch Heisey's Green Bar life series on
your blog.
We're repeating some of the articles we used last time
and found other articles that support some of the topics
our adult leadership group wants to emphasize this time.
As always, it promises to be fun and interesting.
Thanks, Dave.
I'm glad that you're finding those articles useful.
If you don't know about Enoch Heisey's articles on the
blog Green Bar life,
These are aimed at youth leaders from a youth leaders
standpoint and you definitely want to go and check those
out at scoutmastercgcom.
David Goldenberg got in touch and said: love your site.
Use the 15 minute patrol leader training today.
Keep up the great work.
I hope you keep blogging in the coming years, but also
enjoy your retirement.
Well, I will make sure to include a link to my take on
15 minute patrol leader training and. thanks for
getting in touch, David.
We'll definitely be around for a bit on the blog in the
coming years if everything goes according to plan.
Also heard from Ray Britton about last week's podcast
and he said another excellent podcast.
When I became scoutmaster, the tradition was for the
adults to choose all of the youth leaders.
They had a very formal interview process and while
there was some benefit to the scouts with an interview,
it really wasn't the correct way to choose leadership.
When I became scoutmaster, I wanted to change this,
along with a few other things that weren't supporting
the patrol method.
I spoke to my son, who is about 14 years old.
He really wasn't in favor of changing this because
he said the adults would do a better job of picking
the leaders rather than the scouts voting for a friend.
I told him that's one of those lessons we were
taking away from scouts by selecting leaders for them,
and I haven't regretted making that change and
having the scouts elect their leaders for a minute.
Well, Ray, good for you.
Scouts, interestingly, will usually allow adults to
do everything.
If you want to pick all the leaders, well they'll,
they're fine with that.
That removes the responsibility of having them to
deal with it.
If you want to pick out all the food and buy all
the food and prepare all the food and serve it
to them while they sit in their sedan chairs that
you brought along to bring them back and forth
on a camping trip, you know they'll be very happy
to let you do that.
But we know that that just doesn't feel right,
does it? and there's also this kind of strange
recursive loop that some scouts can fall into,
where they'll say: well, we asked the scouts if
they wanted to have elections and they said that
they were happy to have us pick the leaders, and
so, being boy led, we're going to do what they
said and keep picking the leaders.
Well, that's kind of like asking a basketball
team if they like the size of the basketball
court or the height of the nets. you know,
should we make the court a little smaller,
a little larger?
Maybe we should bring those nets down a little
bit. you know, there are some rules involved in
the game and one of the rules of the game is
that scouts elect their leadership.
So good for you, right for knowing there was
some changes that needed to be made and going
ahead and making them.
Also heard from Matthew Godelman and he
said: I came across an article from one of
your blog posts on Pinterest the other night
when I was searching for Cub Scout activities
to do with my weeblows done.
I saw that you had an app and I wanted
to check it out, and I'll make a plug for
the app right now while I'm reading
Matthew's email. the Scout Master CG app
is available for iPhones and iPads and for
Android devices. you find it on iTunes
or at the Google Play app store.
Anyway, go on with what Matthew had to say.
I'm always looking for new ideas to use
with Cubs.
I was my son's Tiger Den leader and I've
held the office of Cub Master for the
past three years.
My wife always tells the story about how
excited I was when my son was born so I
could get out all of my Cub Scout and
Boy Scout stuff.
Hey, there's. there's been a lot of us who
got excited like that, Matt, so good on you.
I'm an electrician in St
Augustine, Florida, and work by myself
most of the time,
So I listened to the podcast on my iPhone.
In fact, in the first three days I started
listening to the podcast, I've covered
about 70 of them,
Holy Moly.
I don't know if this is a record in the
shortest amount of time going through
the archives, but I might be in
contention.
Well, you know we haven't been keeping
records, but, Matthew, I would say that
70 podcasts in three days is definitely
a record and maybe an indication of
needing professional help of some kind.
But
no, I'm glad you're enjoying the
podcast. seriously,
I wanted to let you know how much I'm
enjoying all of this and I can't wait
to listen to the rest of the podcast.
Thanks so much for doing this.
It's been a blast listening to it.
Well, thank you, Matthew,
I'm glad you're enjoying the podcast
and thanks for getting in touch with us.
and don't get your wires crossed, please.
Okay,
Last week on the blog posted the
Court of Honor FAQ that I mentioned
before, and there's a good comment
streams of that. you should go check
it out at scoutmastercgcom.
It's called the Court of Honor FAQ
and just dealing with some common
things about Courts of Honor and how
they work and making some suggestions,
giving some advice, as always. and also
there's another good comment stream
from last week's podcast with some
great comments about some of the
things we discussed, from Frank Maynard,
who is the author of Bob White
Blather- and I've mentioned that blog
several times, but Frank is aimed
very specifically at helping troop
committee people figure things out.
So you definitely want to check
out his blog and check out the comments
on last week's podcast.
Now, if you are a regular
reader and listener, if the information
and the inspiration and ideas
offered by scoutmastercgcom
have helped you out, you can return
the favor by making a one-time
contribution as a scoutmastercgcom
backer. the funds we get
from backers go towards the expenses
of producing and publishing the
podcast and the blog posts
and the videos that are accessible
for Scouters all over the world.
It's easy to do: just go to
scoutmastercgcom,
click the support link at the top
of the page and you can choose
any level of support. some of them
entitle you to premiums like autograph
copies of my books.
I want to take a moment and personally
thank Ralph Ospog and Michael
Manager, who signed up to be back
or since our last podcast.
Thank you so much.
You're the folks that make all
this possible and I really, really
do appreciate it.
Well, in this podcast and
Scout MasterChip- in seven minutes
or less, our fourth and final
installment about basics of the
patrol method. and this week
we're going to be talking about
how to make the patrol method
happen if it's not already happening
in your troop. and then we've got
several email questions to answer
and that's going to take up
the remainder of the podcast.
so let's get started, shall we?
Scout MasterChip in seven minutes
or less.
So this is our fourth installment
of our four part series
about the patrol method.
The first time we got together
to talk about this, we identified
the patrol method as being
the character builder.
The patrol is the character
school of scouting and
that's our main aim. so we need
to have the patrol method
active and vital to really
achieve the aims of scouting.
and then, the second time
we got together about this,
we discussed the adult role
and we talked about the kind
of responsive leadership
that's required to implement
the patrol method. and then
last week, in the third
installment, we talked about
the typical objections
arise in troops where
the patrol method hasn't really
been very effective
or in practice, and we start
working our way towards it.
that objections will arise
and we talked about
how to answer some of those
and to finish up
with the with the series,
this week we want to talk
about actually putting
things into practice.
just a couple of key concepts
about how to make this
work in a very practical way.
Now, trying to work with patrols
as though it was 1810
instead of 2014
is kind of like sending
a telegram in the age of
email. we have to tweak
our application,
the patrol method,
because things have
changed over the last
century. the basic,
broad, underlying principles
are the same,
but some of the applications
are going to be
slightly different
and what I do
that I find effective
with my troop is
going to be different
in some practical
ways than what you do
Now. a century ago,
the whole patrol idea
was basically based
on the neighborhood gang,
and that's exactly
what Baden Powell called it.
boys naturally form
this kind of
neighborhood group
or gang
and he levers
that kind of naturally
occurring grouping
in the way that he built
the scouting program.
but remember, a century ago
boys could just kind of
cross the street
and walk into each other's
houses
and organized youth
sports leagues
and youth clubs
and other activities
weren't all that common.
there was a lot more
in the way of
unscheduled free time.
today scouts
are much more mobile,
so their neighborhood
gang is
not necessarily going to
be confined geographically
to a place
they can walk
and there's a much
bigger organized
menu of activities
that are planned
and scheduled
that they have
choices from
now.
that's not to say that
it used to be good
and now things are bad.
I don't believe that
for a moment.
it's just a different
set of conditions
now. from observing
hundreds of troops
over the years,
it's clear that
most of us
have a more
troop oriented
rather than
patrol method
oriented way
of doing things
and patrols
become more of
an administrative
nicety
of dividing boys up
into smaller groups
than they are
actual
living patrols-
and you know
a lot of our talk
and a lot of our training
in scouting-
reinforces the idea
that the troop
is the central organization
and the organizational charts
put all the adults
at the top
and the scouts
at the bottom
and it sends a pretty
clear signal,
doesn't it?
that the scout master
and his assistants
are in charge of things
and they simply
delegate
responsibilities
to the scouts.
they allow
scouts
to have
responsibility.
while I have
five practical
bits of advice
that can help
shape
a more
21st century
approach
to the patrol method,
and the first is
is to redraw
that organizational chart.
and it's kind of
hard to talk
about an organizational
chart on a podcast.
I can't show it
to you,
but if you look
at the post
that contains
this podcast,
I put my redrawn
organizational chart
right there,
and charts
can do just
so much,
but it
kind of presents
a picture.
it's meant to
graphically represent
that the only reason
we have troops
is to serve
patrols
and patrols
serve scouts
and all of the resources
and all of the organization
and administration
is aimed
at that individual
scout
who is a member
of his patrol
and his patrol
just happens
to be
part of a troop.
the patrol
leaders council
exists
only to serve
patrol leaders
and the support
network
of adults
exists
only to serve
the patrol
leaders council
and, by extension,
then
the scouts
themselves.
the various positions
of responsibility
in a scout
troop
exists
to form
another support
network
for the patrol
leaders council.
so basically,
you can
take the chart
and turn it upside down,
put the scouts
at the top,
put all of the adults
at the bottom.
put the patrol
leaders council
in between
and you have a much
better idea
and you get
a better
mental picture
of how things
are actually arranged.
the second
thing
that's vital
to
a lively
patrol method
is that
scouts
form their own
patrols
and choose
their own leaders.
and when I say
things like that,
this causes a lot of
agita
sometimes.
now
if a scout
isn't in a
patrol
with his
friends,
he's not going
to observe
the structure
of the patrol
because
he's going to
gravitate
towards his
friends
anyway.
then
the patrol
leader
is going to
be chasing
scouts
out of
the wrong
patrol
or searching
for
his
lost sheep
all the time.
and when
the adults
in a troop
decide to do
a little
social
engineering,
they sit down
and they come up
with uniform,
balanced patrols
and that
makes perfect
sense.
point of view,
it certainly
does.
but from
a scouts
point of view
it makes
absolutely
no sense,
because
he's in a
patrol
over here
with guys
he had-
he doesn't
know-
and his friends
in a
patrol
over there
and on a
camping
trip
or at a
meeting.
you know
what's going
to happen.
he's going
to find
his friend
and that's
what's going
to happen.
so
one
of the
reasons
we want
scouts
to form
their own
patrols
is because
they're
going to form
patrols
that
best work
for them,
and that's
the point
right.
once they set,
all of this
takes
a very
few minutes
when
scouts
are doing
it.
and now
tenure
towards a
position of
responsibility
and rank
requirements
have driven
the interval
of leadership
elections
in most
places.
it's
kind of putting
the cart
before the
horse,
right.
I have
no problem
with patrols
electing a
patrol
leader whenever
they want.
a lot of
times
that period
of time
where they decide
they want
to have a
patrol
leader election
is longer
than
the
tenure requirements
for a
position of
responsibility
for
a patrol
leader.
sometimes
it's shorter,
it doesn't matter.
it should be
based on
what the
scouts
want to do
and the
way that it's
going to
work best
for their
patrol.
now
what I'm
describing
makes
all the
patrols
a little more
fluid,
then
fixed
and efficient
and
evenly numbered,
because
when scouts
are able to
choose up
their own patrols,
some of the
patrols
may be
five or
six,
some of the
patrols
may be
eight or
10.
there's
some basic
rules of thumb
to follow
and I would say
you know
patrol
under-
even though I've seen patrols of three work pretty well-
and a
patrol
over eight
or ten
members
is going to be
a little too big.
there's a
scale
to all this
and so
when I'm advising my scouts about the selection of patrols
and how they're
going to
make up patrols,
you know
I say
aim between five
and ten
and that seems
to work
the best.
but there are
always exceptions
to the
rule,
right,
and you know.
to tell you
the truth,
if we
looked at the way
that are
fixed,
adult, chosen
patrols
function,
we'd have to admit that there are much more fluid in practice
than we think.
the patrol member
whose best friend is in another patrol wanders over to that
patrol.
like I explained,
when less than four or five patrol members show up for a
camping trip,
they get
folded into another patrol.
it
is all
a little
pretty fluid
to begin with
in a lot of ways.
so instead of our ideal picture of what a patrol ought to look
like,
let's have the scouts
make
those choices,
because it directly affects them
and they'll get very good at it once they have a little bit of practice.
the third thing
I think
is kind of self-evident,
but let's mention it anyways:
let's be patrol centric.
instead of thinking of the troop all the time,
let's think of patrols.
now our patrol leaders council started scheduling patrol meetings in lieu of troop meetings at least once a month.
there's no troop meeting that night,
only patrol meetings planned and presented by patrol leaders.
they're held at the same time and places- troop meetings
because this is a good way
to get everybody together.
with the constraints of scheduling and the fact that our scouts are spread out over a large geographical area, that one night a week
that we have planned to get together
is a good night. just say okay, no troop meeting tonight, only patrols. patrol leaders plan something,
there you go.
they can function independently as a patrol on that night
without having to try and overcome all the logistical hurdles of doing it on a separate time at a separate time or in another place.
and then every outing and event that the troop has needs to be based on the interest of patrols working together.
we may have a troop camp out, but on that troop camp out
we make sure that the patrols camp together,
they cook and eat together, they hike together and they do everything together.
we want to pay attention to the patrol
because the patrol focuses on the individual scout
and we don't want to treat our scouts as one big herd.
and there are very practical results of that,
and let me point one out.
one thing that comes up when we discuss backpacking is I usually hear from somebody
who says: yeah, we go backpacking, but how do you handle the stragglers, you know,
the younger scouts or the smaller scouts or the not so fit scouts
who end up in the back of the herd,
you know, kind of dragging their way along the trail?
and I'm very familiar with that problem because we had it years and years ago that when we went backpacking it was kind of:
you know, the troop is going backpacking, it's every man for himself.
here we go
and when the first hour of the hike, of course
the guys who are a little slower are going to end up at the back of the pack
and the guys who are really fast are way ahead of the herd there.
how we did away with that happening was actually pretty simple.
you go with your patrol, you hike with your patrol, the whole troop is there,
but you stick together with your patrol.
that can be a bit of a challenge for the scouts, but you know what
they seem to do it. they do it just fine.
and we no longer have a big herd of scouts hiking.
we have patrols hiking who are sticking together
and there's no three or four slow guys wandering around at the back of the herd.
so that's one practical result of focusing not on a troop or a herd of scouts,
but individual patrols.
the fourth thing about the practical ways of applying the patrol method
is that adults have to keep their distance,
and what I mean by this is youth leaders are not going to lead much
if an adult is standing right there.
we have more influence on this than any of us really think.
of course we lead and present and organize everything better than a scout.
we do a much better job of it. it's less chaotic,
we can command attention,
we can make things happen,
but when we do that, we've taken the opportunity away from that patrol leader
or the senior patrol leader
or any of the other scouts tasked with doing something.
so we need to keep our distance.
now what does it? what do I mean by that?
we're far enough away to observe,
but we're not close enough to be heard
unless we raise our voices.
that's just kind of my rule of thumb.
now. this makes most of us pretty uncomfortable at first.
I mean, how will scouts know what to do
if we're not? they're telling them exactly what to do,
how will they know?
or what if they behave poorly? or what if they get hurt?
aren't I supposed to be teaching them things
and telling them what to do?
and I mean, to our minds
they're either awfully young to have that kind of responsibility
or just old enough to make real trouble
if we can't keep an eye on them.
I can't really tell you step by step
how you're going to make this happen.
I can tell you it's possible
and if you make it your goal,
you'll get there
and you won't feel so uncomfortable when you do.
keeping your distance
and letting scouts lead
and letting them do things
is very important to the successful implementation
of the patrol method.
and finally, the fifth thing that I will tell you
is be open to new ideas,
rethink and retool
and rebuild.
I had to kill some of my sacred cows
because they weren't getting the results
that was actually reaching
and benefiting scouts.
nice, neat organizational administration,
controlling the variables,
focusing on the indicators rather than
what was really going on.
it wasn't really doing much for my scouts.
when I accepted that the patrol method
drives everything else-
it drives advancement,
membership,
attendance-
you know it is these core of what we do?
I started focusing more on patrols.
when I started focusing on patrols,
I found myself focusing more and more on scouts
instead of measuring what they do.
I also began to understand the sense
behind all the policies and procedures
were trusted to follow.
patrols aren't intended to break a troop up
into more manageable administrative segments
and make your job as a scout leader easier.
patrols are the central unit of scouting
and troops are just containers for patrols.
patrols are the character school
where scouts lead, instruct and guide each other,
where all the real work happens.
so we need to turn that chart upside down.
we need to focus on patrols,
make our activities patrol centric,
step back,
let the scouts make choices,
give them plenty of latitude
to be able to lead themselves
and be ready to make changes
when it makes sense to improve and strengthen
our application of the patrol method.
in these past four podcasts,
we've introduced the subject,
we've given you the main points.
there's always ways to improve our approach to this
and I leave you with this thought
from our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell,
who said: the patrol is the unit of scouting,
always,
whether for work or for play,
for discipline or for duty,
and you can't come up
with a much higher authority than that.
the patrol is the unit of scouting.
always
take me back to dream again:
by campfire on the trail,
by campfire on the trail
when day is done,
when day is done.
write me a letter,
send it by name
email. that is, folks.
and here's an answer to one of your emails.
well, let's see,
there have been a lot of email questions lately
and I welcome them.
I'm certainly not complaining
and you can get in touch with me.
you'll find out how to do that
at the end of the podcast,
so I just wanted to take a moment to say:
if you haven't gotten an answer from me,
be patient with me.
like I said,
there's been a lot of emails
coming in the past couple of weeks.
I heard from Joseph Gray,
who is with Scout Troop 384
in Temecula, California,
and he said: I've recently discovered
your website
and your articles
regarding the patrol method.
I'm really curious to see how the boys
and our troop would divide themselves
into their own patrols,
but I'm uncertain how to proceed.
I thought I maybe would tell them
to pretend that our current patrols
didn't exist and take five minutes
to form their own patrols.
my fear is that this approach
could backfire in a number of ways.
they may start from the reference
of their current patrols,
and those patrols
that are more active
may stay somewhat intact
and swell to an unmanageable size.
the exercises described
could be very uncomfortable
for some of the boys
if they weren't chosen to be in a patrol.
I'm sure there's a much better approach
to what I described.
what would your advice be?
Well, Joseph,
I'm glad you found ScoutMasterCGcom
and got in touch,
so I was glad to hear
that things are useful for every.
what I'd advise you to do
is to ask all the questions
and communicate all the concerns
that you express
in that email
with your senior patrol leader
and your patrol leaders council.
you might sit with them
and say something like:
I've been doing a little studying lately
and thinking about our patrols.
do you guys think
we could do a better job
of deciding how patrols are made up?
What do you think is important
about this?
How would you change things?
See, if you can imagine
a conversation
where you're not really
telling anything,
you're just asking questions
and listening to answers,
you're helping them discover
what comes next,
start by
talking to one individual Scout.
I would say the senior patrol
leader is a good place to start,
because if you try
and do this with a group,
you know the secret laws,
rules of boyhood
kick in when they're together
in a group,
because it's not cool
to talk honestly
and openly with adults,
right?
so start with one,
ask some questions
and see what kind of answers
you got,
and you're going to find some guidance
in how to make this happen
in those answers.
and while we're talking about questions,
I have questions
of my own
for you too.
so who's responsible
for making things
happen in your troop?
what decision making
is being done by adults
and what do Scouts decide?
who makes announcements
at troop meetings,
for example?
who prepares
and presents
the program
at meetings
and on outings?
I have a very
unscientific
patrol method
self assessment tool
that
I'll link to
in the post
that contains this podcast,
but it's a format
you can sit down
and you can look at
and fill out
and see
if you can assess
how well you're applying
the patrol method.
so instead of
trying to be in control
or just experiment
with the way
patrols are arranged,
I would start asking
Scouts questions,
see what kind of answers
they came up with
and what
next actions
those answers indicated.
now you say you have some concerns
about the things
that would happen
if you kind of open the door
to this sort of thing.
well,
we all have those
kinds of concerns
and,
as I said,
the best place
to share those
is with your patrol
leaders. council.
look,
I think you guys
should set up your own patrols.
but
here's what I'm
concerned about.
can you do it
and consider those concerns
at the same time-
and you know what
they certainly can,
and when you open up a dialogue
with them
and you start talking
about these things,
lots of answers
will be right there.
for obvious reasons,
I'm withholding
the
specifics
about this next
email question.
a scout in our troop
was suspended from school
for a very distasteful
prank.
he played a school dance.
I discussed the situation
with one of my assistant
scout masters
and he believes
the incident
was not at a scout event
and merits
no disciplinary action
from the troop.
I feel, however,
that this
an integrity issue
for a scout
who happens to be
life rank,
and that this
needs to be addressed.
I don't know
if his prank
was out of maliciousness
or just stupidity,
or perhaps both,
and I wanted to know
how you might handle
this sort of situation.
well,
I think there was probably
one percent maliciousness
involved in 99
percent stupidity.
scouts
and boys
at this age.
they sometimes don't think
and they think
they're going to be really,
really cool
in the eyes of their peers
and they do some stupid thing.
then they get in trouble
and you know,
thank goodness
we get second
and third
and fourth chances
at that age.
one of my first bits of advice
is that
the scouters
and troops
don't punish
or discipline scouts.
we don't
involve ourselves
in any of that.
that's the job
of a scout's family,
of his parents
or guardians.
we deal only
in proportionate consequences,
never in punishment.
this scouts
already been punished.
they've been suspended
from school
and there's probably
a few things
that their parents
have done
to embellish
being suspended
from school
as well.
now the behavior
didn't happen
in a scout activities.
there are no actual
physical consequences
to be addressed
as far as scouts go.
so I believe
in that sense
your assistant scout master
is right.
it didn't happen
in scouts
and other than having
a discussion
with the scout,
I wouldn't
do anything else,
especially since
scouts
and troops
don't punish
or discipline
anyone.
ask this question:
if the scout
did something like this
during a scout activity,
would you
expect disciplinary
action from his school?
it wouldn't be fair
or particularly useful,
would it?
now you do
want to sit down
with the scout
and discuss
your concerns
about what happened
and discuss
your concerns
about their personal
integrity.
now, when you
go to do that-
it's my guess
that
the scout
is probably
already pretty embarrassed
and ashamed
at this point-
and
you may be able
to help them
make the best
of a difficult situation.
speaking for myself,
I did plenty
of stupid things
at that age
and it would have been
great to have
an understanding
adult
to talk to.
the last thing
I needed
is somebody else
piling on
with another
punishment
or judgment.
yes,
I understood.
I did
something
wrong.
I've been
punished.
you don't
have to tell me
how wrong
I was.
you don't
have to punish
me
a second time.
what I would have
welcomed
was
someone
who,
as a friend
and mentor,
kindly
and cheerfully
helped me work
through
the situation
and who
would
knew
that
I was capable
of being
a better person
and encourage
me
to do
just that.
you know,
when you think
about it,
situations
like this
can become
pivotal events
in our lives
and they can
really
have an effect
on
who we become
in the future.
how adults
around us
react
to this type
of situation
can either
aggravate it
or make it worse,
or help
see our way
through it
and use them
as a stepping
stone
to being
a better person.
the only time
I've ever taken
actions
regarding
misbehavior
outside of
scouts
was in a situation
that involved
a threat of
physical violence
and then
ended up
in the hands
of the police.
now the scout
who was involved
in that.
we told him
he couldn't be
actively involved
until the
charges
against him
were resolved.
he was exonerated
subsequently.
he came back,
participated
with the troop,
no problem.
the actions
of the scout
who you told me
about.
they were stupid
and maybe even
a little malicious,
but I don't believe
they represent
anything more
than
adolescent
stupidity.
if they did
involve
a direct threat
of physical
violence
or some other
action
that I thought
represented
a risk
to the safety
of their fellow
scouts,
I may have
to treat the situation
differently.
but you
have the opportunity
to be able
to sit down
and have
a
good discussion
with this
young man
and
help him
find his way
through
his present
difficulties
into becoming
a better person,
and that's
the
whole aim
of our work
as scouters.
Paul Fife
is the scout master
of troop 510
in Belton, Missouri
and he writes
to say:
I have become
a scout master
podcast
attic
in the past
two weeks,
while we do
have a
12-step
program
in a group.
and
no,
actually
we don't,
Paul.
but
anyway,
I have a question
regarding a topic
I believe
you mentioned
on a previous
podcast.
can a scout
hold a position
like troop
quartermaster
and patrol
leader
at the same time?
I always
seem to have
parents
complain
that their boy
did not
get a leadership
position
because
another scout
ran
and obtained
more than one.
I explained to them
that
the
scouts
elect their
leaders
and if their son
didn't
get elected,
it's
maybe they
felt
he wasn't
ready.
boys in a good balance
of age groups.
do you have any
thoughts on this?
well, Paul,
to answer your
first question,
the answer is
no.
scouts
don't hold
multiple positions
of responsibility
at the same time.
quartermasters
and other
positions of
responsibility,
by the way,
aren't
elected
and there's
some important
reasons
why they aren't.
now, this isn't
just my opinion,
it's there
in black and white
in the scout
master's
handbook.
according to
the handbook,
there are
two elected
positions:
senior patrol
leader
and patrol leader.
all other
positions
of responsibility
are not
elected
but appointed
with the scout
master's
approval
by the senior
patrol leader
or,
in the case of
patrol
positions of
responsibility,
by the
patrol leader.
so, reading
from the scout
master's
handbook.
it says this:
depending upon
the size
and needs
of the troop,
all are
more of the following
positions
may be filled,
unless otherwise
indicated.
the senior
patrol leader
selects
the scout
who will hold
each position.
the scout master
can help
the senior
patrol leader
make
his decisions
on the basis
of
the candidate's
overall
qualifications
rather than
merely on
friendships.
scouts
serving in
any of the
following
troop positions
continue to be
active members
in their
patrols.
and
what follows
is a list
of
all of the positions
of responsibility
in the troop
quarter: master,
scribe,
etc.
and if you read
through
the next
part of the scout
master's
handbook,
there's
no indication
in any of
the descriptions
of those positions
that they're filled
in any other way
than
the senior
patrol leader
appointing them.
now, this isn't my opinion.
once again,
it's not an
optional
approach.
this is the
way that
scouting
work
and there's
very good reasons
why we don't
have elections
for anybody else
other than
the senior
patrol
leader
and the
patrol
leaders.
think about
our own
representational
system
of government.
we don't
elect positions
like
the chairman
of the joint
chiefs of staff,
for the secretary
of education.
those positions
are appointed
and then
go through
an approval
process
by the representatives
we do
elect,
and those appointments
aren't on the ballot
because they're
based,
hopefully,
on the skills
and experience
of the appointee
rather
than
the appointee's
political popularity,
and you see exactly
how this translates
into what we do
in scouts.
there are only
two elected positions
and the remainder
of the positions
of responsibility-
and they're not
leadership positions,
but more about
that in a moment.
they're all
appointed
according to the candidates
overall qualifications
rather than
merely on their popularity
or their fact
that their friends
with the senior
patrol leader.
so when the senior
patrol leader
appoints these positions,
he ought to be thinking
about having
as many scouts
involved in positions
with responsibility
as possible
and suiting
the scouts
that he chooses
to the job.
as it says,
these appointments
are made
with the scout masters
approval
and, in my opinion,
most of the time
that should be
yep.
that sounds
like a good choice,
but that doesn't mean
that there's
no guidance involved.
if the senior
patrol leader
wanted to
appoint the same guy
to two positions
of responsibility,
I would have some
questions
origin from doing so.
the other important
piece of the puzzle
here
is there are
no leadership
positions.
we only
have positions
of responsibility.
look at the rank
requirements
for star
life
and evil-
no leadership
positions
involved.
does that mean
that we don't
teach leadership
or anything
like that.
well, no,
no, don't,
don't.
don't go
off the deep end
here,
but if you
look at this,
the only positions
of leadership
that are
specifically
leadership
or the senior
patrol
leader
and patrol
leader-
but not
every position-
requires
leadership.
all of the positions
do require
responsibility
and the
guide to advancement
says it better
than I can,
and if you look,
do you have your
pencil ready?
here's the section
that you'll find it in
the guide to advancement
2013:
4.2,
0.3,
0.4,
0.6
man. I feel like
Barney Fife,
but that section
is titled
responsibility
and leadership
and it reads
thusly:
many suggest
this requirement
should call for
the position
of leadership
rather than simply
responsibility.
taking an accepting
responsibility,
however,
is a key foundation
for leadership.
one cannot
lead effectively
without it.
the requirement,
as written,
recognizes
the different
personalities,
talents
and skill sets,
and all of us-
some seem to be
the leader
of the group,
others
provide
quality support
and strong
examples
behind the scenes.
without the ladder,
the leaders in charge
have little chance
for success.
thus, the work
of the supporters
becomes
part of the overall
leadership
effort.
I sent that answer
to Paul
and he
wrote back
and said:
that's good
information,
thank you.
we just
had elections
for all those
positions
last night.
I wish I had
asked you
sooner.
we have
always done
it that way.
do you ever
hear complaints
from parents
of scouts
who don't
get an appointed
position,
maybe because
they're not friends
with the senior
patrol leader?
my reply
to him was:
you know,
I don't
recall
any time
that a parent
has complained
about their son
not being appointed
to something
or other,
and this is probably
because
we don't
make appointments
based on friendship.
you know,
as I said,
it's the
scout master's job
to advise
and make sure
that that's
not happening.
my guess is,
the complaints
that you're
getting, Paul,
are because
you aren't
following the program
and
this is resulting
in a selection
process
that's more
based on popularity
than merit
or ability.
now
I'm being
a bit of a pain
here,
I know,
and all this
is attended
in the best
spirit possible,
but
that's the way
we've always
done. things
is never
a good reason.
it's never
too late
to change.
you can go
next week
to your troop
meeting,
get the
patrol leaders
council together,
explain the
mistake
and ask
what they think
they ought to do
next
to fix it.
this may be
very energizing
to the
patrol leaders
council,
but it may upset
a few adults
involved.
you may
have to manage
that.
as I often
say,
the scout master
advises
and mentors
in council
scouts
so they can
lead themselves.
but the scout
master
leads
the other adults.
they chose you
for the job
and that means
they need to
follow your
directions
and it's
the scout master's job
to keep things
on track.
if you were the coach
of a basketball team,
you play on a
basketball court
with a basketball
and follow
the rules of the
game.
you don't take
a basketball team
to a baseball diamond
and play football
right.
you train your
youth leadership
in the rules
of the game
of scouting
and this is the context
for everything
they do
and all the
decisions
they make.
this is the direction
we're all
traveling in.
this takes
some choices,
like
you know.
let's elect
the quarter master
off the table,
and it also
marks out
the field of
play.
their decisions
and actions
have to
follow the
program.
now, this sounds
limiting
at first
but I can
tell you
from experience
is very
energizing
once scouts
know the
rules of the
game
they love
to play.
now, in a way,
you just
aren't the
coach,
you're kind
of the
referee
too.
every scout
master
is
ever
play a game
where the
ref didn't
know the rules
is pretty
frustrating
for everybody.
the folks
that were
there
before
you may
not have
read the
rulebook,
so now
it's up to you
to make
sure that
everybody's
playing by
the rules.
you've been
doing things
one way.
you guys
had it
wrong.
no harm,
no foul.
you just need to
change the way
that you're
doing things.
if you take
those
changes to the
scouts
and you ask them
for a solution,
you'll find
it's pretty
easy
and actually
a whole lot
of fun.
thank you for listening
to this
238th
edition
of the scout
master
podcast.
here's
how you
can keep
in touch.
read
the blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and, while
you're there,
you can
subscribe
to receive
updates
to the
blog
by
email.
you can get
the scoutmaster
cg
app
that
we spoke
about earlier
on
Google
Play
or in the
iTunes
app
store.
you can experience
the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
through the
vast
panorama
of social
media.
that's
right.
join
the
folks
who like
scoutmaster
blog
on
Facebook.
tweet along
with the chorus
of
11 hundred
tweeters
on Twitter.
pinned the
poultrytuteness
pictures
proffered
publicly,
with
other prolific
pinners
on Pinterest.
watch us,
if you dare,
at scoutmastercg
on YouTube.
join
the 400
odd folks
who form
the exclusive
scoutmaster
circle
on Google
Plus.
but
Facebook,
if Twitter
makes you better,
if you have
no interest
in Pinterest,
if you don't
put the
you in YouTube,
if you're a
minus
when it comes
to Google
Plus,
that's
all right.
Bunky,
zoom
in to the late
90s
and send me
an email.
you can
get in touch
with me
at
Clark
scoutmaster
cgcom,
CLA
RKE
at
scoutmaster
cgcom.
the scoutmaster
blog
and the
scoutmaster
podcast
and all the
other wonderful
things
we do
are not official
publications
of the Boy Scouts
of America,
nor are they endorsed
or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts
of America,
or any other
organization
for that matter,
because
I am
sure
they have
much better things
to do
with their time.
now it's just me
talking into
a microphone,
trying to lend
a hand to
scout leaders
and have a little
bit of fun
along the way.
incidentally,
speaking
of fun,
here's
our founder,
Sir
Robert
Baden
Powell.
Sir
Robert,
Good luck
to you
and good
camping
Hawaii.
thank you,
sir,
until next time,
everyone.